[Applaus]
62 62
hallo ich heiße erichsen
ich bin 29 jahre alt ich komme aus
schweden und wohne in bern
ich spreche schwedisch englisch und ich
lerne deutsch ich bin ledig ich arbeite
als architekt
am morgen stehe ich um zwanzig nach 7
auf
entschuldigung können sie mir sagen wo
hier die apotheke ist ja klar
gehen sie in den zweiten stock dort ist
die apotheke in der mitte
hallo hallo hier ist daniel hallo daniel
gut danke und dir auch gut was machst du
ich koche etwas zu mittag und du ich
mache gerade die hausaufgaben aber ich
verstehe sie nicht
deshalb rufe ich auch an verstehst du
sie ja
kannst du mir helfen ja sicher aber im
moment bin ich gerade am kochen klar und
erklären am telefon ist auch schwierig
können wir uns später im café treffen ja
gut wo und wann im café um halb fünf das
ist ein bisschen spät
ich gehe am abend in die yogastunde
können wir früher ab machen
um halb vier einverstanden
halb vier ist gut macht yoga ja immer am
montag und mittwoch am abend eine stunde
gut ich muss jetzt kochen bis später
danke und tschüss
gestern bin ich früh aufgestanden zuerst
bin ich gleich ins fitnesscenter
gegangen und habe trainiert
danach habe ich gefrühstückt
dann habe ich im supermarkt lebensmittel
eingekauft
danach bin ich zur arbeit gefahren
ich habe im büro gearbeitet
nach der arbeit habe ich auf der bank
geld abgehoben
am nachmittag bin ich zu meinem arzt
gegangen
er hat mich untersucht nach dem
arzttermin bin ich mit dem bus ins
zentrum gefahren
ich habe den bus genommen weil ich mit
meiner freundin im restaurant zum
abendessen ab gemacht habe
natürlich wollte ich auch wein trinken
nach dem essen sind wir ins kino
gegangen im kino haben wir einen
spannenden film gesehen